we're continuing to monitor our breaking
news and there may be a major
development happening right now let's
get right live to the scene and
investigator vanessa murphy
sources tell me robert tellis is in
custody again sources are telling me
robert tellis is in custody after we've
been here for hours in sort of a
barricade situation again robert tell us
public administrator who has become the
center of a homicide investigation is
now in custody according to my sources
i'll step out of the way so you can see
the scene here and i'll give you some
background
he again is the public administrator of
clark county
earlier an officer knocked on his door
there was no answer that was about a
couple of hours after police dropped him
off in a white jumpsuit around two after
executing a search warrant at his home
and taking two vehicles and his clothes
now again the victim
in the homicide investigation is
investigative reporter jeff gearman okay
i'm going to step out of the way so you
can see
we see fire leaving the scene here
metro leaving the scene again you can
just see how many vehicles
are here
we're going to step out of the way so
again
robert tellis became the center of this
homicide investigation the victim was
investigative journalist from the review
journal jeff german german was found
stabbed to death outside his northwest
valley home
on saturday morning police say they
believe he was killed on friday morning
again you see a metro vehicle a fire
vehicle leaving the scene this
neighborhood has really been on lockdown
so again robert tellis is in custody the
public administrator of clark county who
became the center of a homicide
investigation the victim investigative
journalist jeff gehrman who had reported
on telus and exposed issues in his
office again robert tellis is in custody
according to my sources reporting live
vanessa murphy 8 news now
so much happening there today with two
vehicles taken this morning including
that gmc yukon denali that maroon denali
which was seen at the crime scene again
as vanessa pointed out
tulas dropped back at that home wearing
a white paper painter jumpsuit at about
2 15 p.m vanessa and channel 8 there
getting trying to get word from him as
he headed into his garage then police
back on scene and for hours now we've
been reporting on their efforts to make
some contact with him now we're getting
word from vanessa that he is in custody
all of this of course stemming from the
murder that happened friday evening the
discovery of his body not until saturday
but metro police categorizing this as a
major case for them working very quickly
and it looks like they may have
their man in custody all right